okay I have a voicemail number the
number is two one nine to david p really
specific question in today's voicemail
that i am going to play for you here
take a listen to this i'm just wondering
if you actually are listening to these
calls and if you are i'd appreciate it
if you are played this match thank you
all right so uh you're welcome we're
playing the message i don't know what
we're accomplishing exactly because of
course I'm listening to the calls we
play a call every day and the only way
we could play it is if I listen to it
and select the phone call that were
playing so yes the answer is I am
listening to the voice mail calls and
you can leave voicemails at two one nine
to david p uh on today's bonus show
scientists have bred live mice without
fertilized eggs and this is starting to
open up a conversation about the
possibility of two men being able to
have a child we have more bizarre and
creepy clown sightings to report on and
also NPR has published an anti-trump
comic for teachers and students and i
have a few anecdotes i want to relate to
you about educational professionals and
politics in the classroom david
pakman.com slash membership is the one
place to sign up for the bonus show